NARRATOR: Rick
Lagina, Craig Tester,
and Charles Barkhouse
head over to the area
known as the Money Pit.
They are in the early stages
of finding out if recently
conducted seismic testing
has allowed them to pinpoint
the precise location of
the original treasure
site first discovered in 1795.
Well, got through here.
We're down to 129.
NARRATOR: Just one day ago,
the team from Choice Drilling
began a new 6 and 1/2 inch
wide borehole known as DE6.
There's your wood.
Bring it on over.
NARRATOR: At a depth
of 93 feet, they
discovered evidence of
a horizontal wooden beam
followed by a 3-foot void.
I love it.
It was laying this way--
Yeah.
--not standing up.
It was laying like this.
So it could be the
top of a tunnel.
NARRATOR: It was
at this same depth
that recent seismic
scanning of the area
revealed what could be a
network of underground tunnels.
That carries on
into what looks
like a larger network around
the 100 to 110 footish range.
Flood tunnel?
Could be.
NARRATOR: Is it possible that
Rick, Marty, and their partners
have actually located one of the
legendary booby-trapped flood
tunnels, the tunnels
which many believe
were constructed
in order to prevent
searchers from finding the
centuries-old treasure vault?
What are you
calling the depth?
164.
You getting anything?
It's really soft.
Right.
So you want to keep--
drill another whatever
until you hit something hard?
- Sure.
OK.
NARRATOR: Although the team
is encouraged by locating
a possible tunnel,
they're even more
hopeful to reach another one of
the intriguing anomalies that
was detected by
seismic scanning,
a nearly 30-foot-wide
void at a depth
of approximately 170 feet.
It was at this depth last year
that the team, while drilling
with a 60-inch-wide
steel caisson,
encountered what they believed
could be the legendary Chappell
vault, a 7-foot-tall
wooden box first discovered
by treasure hunters
William Chappell
and Frederick Blair in 1897.
However, instead of
penetrating the vault,
the caisson is believed
to have actually
pushed the mysterious object
further down into the mud
and off to the side.
When we were doing
the big can on H8,
we had a plod where
the bottom of the hole
kept on being
pushed to the side.
So what was being
pushed to the side?
Drilling this well
might indicate
what was pushed aside from H8.
So we're looking for any kind
of evidence in that area.
Fingers crossed we hit the
vault or a debris field
from the treasure
itself falling.
So it was an
excellent place to be.
Well, I hope we have something.
I hope so.
What would that something
be that you'd like?
I'd settle for silver.
I don't need gold right now.
One step at a time, right?
Yeah.
We're on something
really, really hard.
Wow.
NARRATOR: The Oak Island team
has just struck an object
at a depth of some 200 feet
deep underground, an object that
seems impossible to penetrate.
What's your guess?
It looks like we
tagged something
hard, which we assume
to be interface,
bedrock of some sort.
A serious problem for you?
I think this should stop.
We hit something around
the 204, 205 range, so.
NARRATOR: Despite the fact
that the team had previously
recovered promising evidence
from this same borehole,
leading them to believe
they might have located
the original Money Pit
shaft, hitting bedrock offers
a disappointing development.
It means they may have missed
the large underground anomaly
that was indicated on the
3D map created by the team's
recent seismic scanning.
It also means they
will be forced
to choose a different site
in the hopes of locating
the legendary Chappell vault.
We certainly didn't hit
the center of the anomaly.
And, you know, that's
good and bad news.
But as long as the drill
is down hole, there's hope.
As usual, with all the things
we've done to date on Oak
Island, there's
things to be learned,
a few more questions,
a few disappointments.
Well, you know, the tunnel
to me, very interesting.
Either if it's an
original, it's fantastic.
If it's a searcher, it helps us
define where the money pit is.
And we need to get
back and look at all
the different maps,
interpretations
of where those tunnels were.
Definite disappointment.
You know, we were hoping
to find, you know, a cavern
at this area, and we didn't.
It's just part of the process.